et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
bruno retailleau bonjour bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nos sénateurs de la
vendée président du groupe l'est
républicain ici au sénat on est ensemble
pendant un peu plus de vingt minutes
pour une interview en partenariat avec
la presse quotidienne régionale
représenté par julien lécuyer de la voix
du nord bonjour julien bonjour avec les
yeux royal on commence évidemment bruno
retailleau par votre réaction à
l'intervention d' emmanuel macron hier
qui a donc annoncé de nouvelles mesures
restrictives
est ce que pour vous ce sont les bonnes
majeur ça veut dire qu'il veut dire à ce
que ce que je veux dire sur
l'intervention d'hier soir c'est que on
a la fâcheuse impression que ses
interventions il y en a eu huit depuis
le début de la crise c'est toujours un
peu les mêmes c'est à dire que on
assiste à une sorte de bégaiement
on nous dit à chaque fois on va créer
des lits des animations on va former des
gens je voudrais simplement dire
qu'avant le deuxième confinement on va
être au troisième confinement c'était le
28 octobre et mal macron vient au
journal télévisé à 20 heures il annonce
7000 soignants qui seront formés où sont
ils il annonce dix mille lits de
réanimation il fait la même annonce hier
alors de deux choses l'une ou bien ce
qui nous avait dit en octobre était faux
ou bien à ce moment là ce sera la
réussite c'est un peu la promesse ou les
promesses des macros un peu comme
l'horizon fur et à mesure que on s'en
approche qu'on croit s'en approcher en
tout cas et ça s'éloigne
voilà donc il faut et faire attention
d'autant plus que ces dix mille lits je
vous rappelle que la politique de
confinement en france est piloté par un
indicateur la saturation dans les
hôpitaux de nos lits de réanimation
le problème c'est que ces dix mille lits
on a à peu près 6000 un peu moins de
6000 en temps normal ces lits là on les
a les limites on les a pas qu'est-ce
qu'on fait justement il faut que les
téléspectacteurs le comprenne bien
on va chercher les équipes dans les
blocs opératoires
on déshabille donc des services pour
créer des lits mais ça suppose beaucoup
de moyens
j'avais hier un grand patron d'un grand
hôpital parisien qui me disait qu'il
fallait à peu près
déshabiller deux blocs opératoires pour
un seul lit c'est à dire que pour le
dire différemment et autrement quand
vous avez un malade du coc vide qui est
soigné dans un de ces lits et fait mr
lee éphémère parce qu'ils sont issus de
la déprogrammation de silly là et bien
pour un patient soigné pendant à peu
près 15 jours c'est à peu près 150
autres patients qui ne seront pas opérés
ce que donc le noyau c'est que est a
finalement vous critiquez
l'impréparation quasiment structurelle
du de l'exécutif
et est ce que vous auriez aimé à ce
titre qu'il reconnaisse clairement les
erreurs les erreurs de la crise il l'a
fait un peu du bout des lèvres il a dit
nous avons commis des erreurs mais les a
pas cités il dit nous tirons toutes les
toutes les leçons mais après la crise
c'est ce qu'on comprend ce que vous
pensez qu'il est et il devait faire ce
mea culpa je pense que comme en gala
merkel il aurait pu le faire je pense
qu'il pourrait aussi avoir des
interventions un peu moins théâtralisée
un peu plus sobre
je pense de ce côté-ci d'ailleurs ça
s'améliore je sais que la situation
elle est compliquée et il ya une
modestie avoir mais encore une abaya
auquel avait nommé peut-être que il va
vers la sobriété je le souhaite
voilà d'ailleurs quand il y avait le
contraste entre lui et edouard philippe
à l'époque on voyait bien que ce
contraste tourné à l'avantagé des douars
philippe ce n'est pas par sa
personnalité mais par la sobriété par le
style en réalité un peu plus un peu plus
délicatement ce que ce qui me gêne c'est
ce bégaiement
c'est cette idée que à chaque fois on
remet à demain les promesses qu'on avait
fait hier même chose on nous dit voilà à
partir du mois de mai les musées
pourrait rouvrir bien moi je me souviens
des interventions de juillet-août de
l'an dernier on nous promettait
souvenez-vous des jours heureux
c'était le lundi de pâques je crois en
nous promettait le 14 juillet dans une
allocution au musée ça y est maintenant
les prêts on va y faire face
et hier qu at il dit il a dit la même
chose on a résisté et on a appris voilà
moi je l'espère je crois que il ya que
et j'ai dis quelquefois il ya que deux
stratégies au monde qui se soit montrée
efficace
contre le co lead la stratégie asiatique
c'est à dire le scirocco vie il faut
bien sûr dépister et surtout il faut
isoler on n'est pas capable d'isoler de
bien isoler une étude récemment
l'institut pasteur montré que 97 % de ce
qui était positif
ça fait mal si je vais très très mal et
donc ils comptent amis et puis l'autre
stratégie donc d'abord satellise iroko
vide qui a marché dans les démocraties
d'asie et l'autre c'est la vaccination
massive et ça fonctionne en israël et ça
fonctionne au royaume y regarder au
royaume uni et les français risquent
d'être frustré parce que bientôt ils
vont s'apercevoir que là bas on ré ouvre
on ré ouvre les pubs où on peut
désormais être déjeuner ou dîner
voilà et pareil pour les états unis donc
il va y avoir puisqu'il à part c'est
aussi d'une course de vitesse
bien sûr que nous sommes engagés dans
une course de vitesse et le retard que
nous avons accumulé nous avons toujours
eu puisque lui même avait parlé de
guerre eh bien nous avons toujours eu
une cassure est ce que vous dites ça y
est la vaccination est lancé je ne peux
pas vous dire je vais vous donner un
exemple au mois de décembre
le premier ministre dit que à la mi mars
à peu près 12 auront 14 millions de
vaccins et vaccination est maintenant
c'est 10 millions au milieu du mois
d'avril
donc ça bouge ça bouge en permanence
donc je ne peux pas vous le dire mais
sur la fermeture des écoles mais sur
retailleau est ce que vous êtes plutôt
en accord avec la stratégie qui a été
définie par le président j'avais proposé
à valérie pécresse est fait aussi qu' on
puisse décaler les quinze jours de
vacances de pâques de printemps pour que
j'ai entendu dans certaines vallées et
finalement je pense que mais c'est ce
qui caractérise le confinement il n'a
pas prononcé le mot mais quelle est la
signature du confinement
c'est évidemment la fermeture des écoles
bien sûr bien sûr pour vous aujourd'hui
on est dans un confinement qui ne dit
pas son nom
on est dans un conflit dont je pense que
ce critère de la fermeture des écoles
c'est la marque évidemment
d'un confinement non moi j'aimerais
qu'on est à prix mais où est la réserve
sanitaire
moi j'ai eu beaucoup de médecins on ne
voit pas dans les airs sanitaires j'ai
parlé de lit là aussi de réanimation
quand je dis qu'on a eu beaucoup de
retard j'étais en contact avec un grand
patron de le laboratoire privé mais sur
le séquençage vous savez qu'en france en
séquence beaucoup moins que le petit
danemark par exemple via une banque de
données pour traquer le virus parce
qu'il ya des mutations
on a parlé de variants anglais sud
africains brésiliens
peut-être même breton donc c'est
important de traquer le virus et bien
nous notre rapport à la base
internationale est très très fait
pourquoi on fait la même erreur qu'avec
les tests pcr
on a privilégié le public au détriment
du privé donc à chaque fois les mêmes
erreurs on les reproduit c'est ça qui me
préoccupe
jean castex et devant le parlement
aujourd'hui ce matin il est à
l'assemblée nationale cet après midi il
sera au sénat quelle sera votre position
concernant ce débat est ce que vous
participerez aux votes vous et les
sénateurs de votre compte
écoutez on va en discuter in en quelques
heures la à 9 heures avec les sénateurs
dont je peux pas anticiper
je peux vous dire ce que je proposerai
je proposerai que on ne participe pas au
vote et je pense que d'autres groupes
que nous-mêmes pourrions avoir la même
attitude pourquoi bien sûr qu'on ne
refuse pas le débat et on va débattre
mais qu'est ce qu'on nous demande on
nous demande de voter sur des mesures à
prendre des mesures qui ont déjà été
prises et des mesures qui ont été déjà
annoncées
le sénat ça n'est pas une chambre
d'enregistrement
le sénat ça n'est pas le greffier des
décisions présidentielles quand nous
votons ici c'est pour voter la loi c'est
un vote est impératif
faut pas confondre de senna avec une
convention citoyenne donc arrêtons ce
jeu qui est un jeu trouble et qui fausse
le jeu démocratique le prison de
république annonce prend les décisions
seul dans son conseil de défense vous le
savez jamais en france le pouvoir
n'aurait été concentrées en si peu de
mains les mains d'un seul présent de
république et ensuite on nous demande
interne et c'est pas comme ça que ça
fonctionne
retailleau excusez moi mais par rapport
à ça vous vous présidence 6 comment
feriez-vous vous organiserez y est
d'abord un débat à l'assemblée nationale
pour voter d une stratégie et des
mesures on perdrait pas trop de temps
non mais je vais vous donner un exemple
ouailles et on nous demande de voter
pour rien sur rien puisque les décisions
sont déjà prises
on est d'accord c'est donc un vote keane
ne sert à rien d'en nous nous avions
proposé quand on a examiné le texte sur
l'état d'urgence que le parlement puisse
vraiment voter lorsqu'il s'agissait de
prolonger un confinement d'un mois est
ce votre corps est inutile le
gouvernement nous la refusez donc c'est
ce que nous demandons nous demandons pas
bien sûr que il ya la vème république il
ya l'exécutif et l parlement faut pas
tout mélanger
vous avez raison il ya besoin parfois de
répondre rapidement mais habillé ensuite
une décision personnelle en décisions
collectives et parlementaires non ça
marche pas comme ça la démocratie la
démocratie c'est pas d'un côté je décide
seul et puis quand j'ai décidé je
demande finalement au parlement de
ratifier ma décision c'est pas ça la
démocratie juste pour qu'on soit bien
clair sur ce qu'il va se passer cet
après midi vous irez dans l'hémicycle
vous écouterai jean castex voulu
répondre et vous vous exprimerez et au
moment du vote vous ne participerez pas
mais c'est jeudi pour l'instant une
proposition mais ce qui serait ce que ma
mère mais s'aimer sénateurs du groupe
qui vont décider mais je pense que voilà
je ne faut pas refuser le débat faut
dire ce que nous avons à dire souligner
ce qui peut être positif et souligner ce
qui ne marche pas on est là aussi pour
ça une opposition c'est pas aussi fait
pour aller toujours un même sens que
l'exécutif sur retailleau il y reçoit
vous l'avez certainement
entendu comme moi justement pas entendu
par un mot sur les régionales et
départementales où vous d'interpréter
comment je pense qu'ils ont voulu
dissocier les deux choses parce que
j'imagine que dans les jours prochains
lire une consultation des chefs de parti
des présidents de groupe pour savoir si
on doit tenir oui ou non les régionales
vous l'imaginez ça veut dire vous n'avez
pas d'information du premier ministre ne
savait pas quand ils consultent j'ai
quelques jours j'ai une petite
information
j'ai une petite information qui demande
à être confirmé selon laquelle la
semaine prochaine il y aura sans doute
cette consultation sous une forme ou
sous une autre
évidemment plus tôt en début de semaine
ou en milieu de semaine peu importe ce
sera l'espagne ça serait la semaine
prochaine mais c'est important parce que
je parlais à l'instant de la démocratie
il ya quand même en france une crise de
la démocratie
voilà donc je pense que attention à ne
pas tripatouiller trop le calendrier
électoral
s'il ya évidemment des urgences
sanitaires on n'a jamais dit non mais
très franchement quand on voit que dans
une douzaine de pays
on a voté parfois avec tes taux de
participation impressionnant je vous
rappelle que pour cent aux pays-bas 4
pour les législatives
on a voté au portugal pour les
présidentielles on a voté aussi pour les
présidentielles il ya un an dans en
pologne aux états unis et pareil pour ce
qui concerne les deux lander allemands
où on avait pratiquement 63 % de
participation
donc attention nous on est dans une
autre perspective on dit attention bien
sûr il ya la santé des français a assuré
donc voyons quelles sont les
propositions qu'on peut faire pour qu'on
puisse voter mais qu'on puisse voter en
toute sécurité un exemple on a mis dans
la loi que désormais quelqu'un qui a une
procuration pourrait avoir deux
procurations
autre exemple qu'on pourrait prendre
dans les communes de moins de 3500
habitants plutôt que puisqu'on aura les
départementales et les régionales plutôt
que d'avoir deux bureaux de vote qui
vendent multiplier les assesseurs et
bien et lyon 2 urne avec des bulletins
de vote de couleurs différentes par
exemple dans la même pièce
pourquoi ne pas prioriser aussi la
vaccination des assesseurs
donc il ya des moyens
de respecter la vie démocratique
d'autres pays européens qui sont plus
modestes plus petit que nous en nombre
d'habitants et de puissance le font
pourquoi est ce que nous on ne le ferait
pas simplement ne votons pas n'importe
comment
et attention aussi à la santé des
français mais pour cela il ya des
mesures de précautions qu'il faut
anticiper on va parler la loi
séparatisme maintenant qu'elle examine
en ce moment au sénat oui grands
dossiers qui vous intéressent
particulièrement puisque vous avez porté
plusieurs amendements à ce texte vous
avez souhaité durci renforcer
interdiction du voile lors des sorties
scolaires alors vous n'avez pas parlé du
voile nommément mais des signes façon
ostentatoire l'interdiction du burkini
et même l'interdiction du port de signes
religieux par des mineurs dans l'espace
public alors question assez simple c'est
ce que vous n'êtes pas en train de
déchirer la loi de séparation de
l'église et de l'état de 1905 par ses
amendements
non pas du tout pas du tout justement
moi je suis pour une application stricte
de la loi de 1905
simplement il vous a pas échappé que la
situation en france elle est
catastrophique
nous l'avons sous nos yeux nous avons eu
plus de 260 morts des centaines de
blessés
un terrorisme qui a frappé et la charia
qui s'applique déjà en france quand on
décapite sam elle pâtit
c'est pour faire peur aux professeurs et
quand vous apprenez dans un sondage fait
pour la fondation d'ailleurs jean jaurès
c'est pas ma crémerie si j'ose dire que
un professeur sur deux 49% à du
s'autocensurer s'autocensurer et cette
proportion a augmenté en deux ans vous
l'entendez bien de 13 points
c'est catastrophique donc est-ce qu'on
veut un texte utile ou pas le texte du
gouvernement n'est pas un texte
suffisamment ferme et déterminé contre
monsieur que par ce parce que vous dites
vous faites une sorte de lien quasiment
direct entre le terrorisme et le port du
burkini ou le port 2
encore une fois de signes religieux tels
que le voile puisque c'est quand même ça
qu'on vise qu'on vise
lors de sorties scolaires je vais vous
semble pas excessif je vais vous
expliquer tous les chercheurs nous
disent aujourd'hui qu'ils un phénomène
gilles kepel parle de djihadisme
d'atmosphère il ya le terrorisme c'est
une manifestation violente
mais il ya aussi le terreau du
terrorisme
voilà qui est en train de gangréner la
république qui a conquis des territoires
qui a conquis des esprits je sépare pas
les deux l'évocation terroristes de
demain c'est l' or le voile par exemple
c'est le symbole du séparatisme
comment voulez vous faire un texte sur
le séparatisme sans atteindre ce qui est
l'étendard du séparatisme le voile le
voile qui dit à la femme
il faut que la femme se soumettent c'est
un symbole sexiste c'est un symbole de
séparation on sait par la communauté des
croyants de la communauté des citoyens
donc oui oui au sénat et je suis très
fier que notre propre groupe puisse
ajouter de la fermeté à ce texte sur la
question du séparatisme sur le délit
séparatistes nous en discuterons à
l'article 4 voilà parce que aujourd'hui
c'est trop faible mais aussi par exemple
sur l'immigration est ce que les
français savent qu'aujourd'hui quelqu'un
qui réfugiés qui bénéficient du droit
d'asile qui bénéficie finalement de
l'hospitalité française peut faire
l'apologie du terrorisme en france sur
notre sol sans être exclusif que claire
bien on rectifiera cette anomalie est
royalement ça il faut du courage
aujourd'hui ce texte pour vous bruno
retailleau c'est pas un moyen d'affirmer
votre ligne politique et d'envoyer un
message aux électeurs de droite en vue
des chances électorales ficr je m'en
fiche je m'en fiche moi j'aime mon pays
la droite pour moi c'est pas une
finalité la finalité c'est la france il
faut être aveugle comme on l'a été
pendant des dizaines d'années pour
continuer dans cette pente dangereuse
est ce qu on dit stop ça suffit ou est
ce qu'on continue ou est ce qu on fait
du faux semblant
ce texte aujourd'hui c'est un faux
semblant comment voulez vous encore une
fois faire un texte qui ne traitent pas
d'immigration le communautarisme c'est
né d'une immigration massive qu'on ne
contrôle plus
avec des nouveaux venus malheureusement
qui ne veulent plus intello
est-ce que vos amendements ne sont ils
pas des également des faux semblants le
conseil d'état déjà en 2016 a déjà
rejeté les arrêtés anti anti burqini on
le sait c'est déjà été actée ces textes
n'ont aucune chance d'aboutir
et surtout qu'ils contreviennent d'une
certaine manière avec la convention
citoyenne des droits de l'homme
européenne avec la constitution
enfin il ya beaucoup de choses qui
semblent dire qu'il va être toute façon
qu'il était impossible que ces textes
passent et bien vous vous trompez le
burqini nous l'imposent ont en tout cas
nous l'interdisent on nous imposons
cette règle dans des espaces fermés dans
des baignades ferney dans des piscines
fermé le conseil d'état avait créé cette
jurisprudence sur des espaces publics
ouverts comme la plage est ce
qu'aujourd'hui la loi de 2004 sur le
voile des à l'école est critiqué est ce
que la loi de 2010 sur la burqa dans
l'espace public et critique et non ce
sont des lois qui ont dit stop
un moment ou un autre c'est ma famille
politique qui les a fait passer et on
avait les mêmes critères en s'appuyant
en s'appuyant pour la loi sur la burqa
sur le fait que c'était un désordre à
l'ordre public ce qui n'est pas du tout
le cas du voile du simple voile mais le
simple voix mâles hétéros nier que ce
soit un désordre de l'ordre public bien
sûr parce que dans les sorties scolaires
les sorties scolaires c'est l'école hors
les murs et la prolongation de l'école
puisque c'est une sortie qui est
obligatoire on l'exploitent avant d'un
point de vue pédagogique
après aussi donc c'est l'école hors les
murs la règle qui s'applique dans
l'école c'est à dire dans les murs elle
doit s'appliquer dans l'école
hors les murs voilà c'est une simple
question de bon sens et ne nous cachons
pas derrière une petite heure vous avez
raison il ya des grandes institutions
internationales dont le comité des
droits de l'homme de l'onu qui a voulu
condamner la france sur la loi de 2010
pourquoi parce que il ya un modèle anglo
saxon quel modèle communautariste
multiculturaliste d'accord mais c'est
pas notre modèle notre modèle c'est le
modèle républicain et laïque qui ne
connaît non pas la juxtaposition des
communautés et du coup une société multi
conflictuelle mais nous
avons-nous une seule communauté la
communauté des citoyens la communauté
nationale
un dernier mot avant de parler politique
gérald darmanin il a demandé aux préfets
d'organiser des assises territoriales
avec les acteurs de l'islam et la
demande et d'en exclure les fédérations
qui n'ont pas signé la charte des
valeurs républicaines est ce que vous le
soutenez dans cette démarche mais
écoutez tous est de l'hypocrisie j'ai
depuis longtemps - critiqué le conseil
français du culte musulman
pourquoi parce que vous avez neuf
fédérations dans les neuf fédérations
vous en avez 4 dont on sait qu'elles
sont gangrénés par l'islam politique par
l'islamisme et vous en avez qui sont
totalement saoul influence étrangère et
mails macron a reçu d'ailleurs ces
fédérations à l'elysée il ya quelques
temps et il voulait confier au cfcm le
soin de former des imams je pense que
pour reparler de la loi 1905
l'état n'a pas à mettre la main dans ce
genre de choses je ne demande pas à et
mal macron de former des imams
je pense que ce qui est important c'est
que on est une stricte application de la
séparation et il faut faire très très
attention
j'ai aussi avancé simon nationalisation
de l'islam de france n'est pas une bonne
piste d'ailleurs et je sais que c'est
nicolas sarkozy d'ailleurs qu'il avait
créée en 2003 mais est ce que le cfcm
nous a protégés des attentats de la
montée de l'isf et non parce que les
radicaux trouveront toujours une voie de
passage contourneront et quelques
questions politiques quant à mme nagy
oui alors je vais vous parler d'un
candidat qui qu'on connaît bien par la
voix du nord le président de la région
de france xavier bertrand qui ces cas
fait acte de candidature dans le journal
le point et ce qu'il a eu raison de
présenter sa candidature en pleine crise
sanitaire et sans attendre le résultat
des régionales de ce qui était sa
primaire pour lui normalement coûter
fois du temps évidemment observent de
très très près ce qui se passe dans les
autres ans je les observe aussi
simplement personne ne peut se dire
surpris de la déclaration de candidature
de xavier il avait déjà fait d'ailleurs
auparavant donc comme en tout cas ça n'a
pas été un scoop pour moi il choisit son
calendrier
il a choisi ce calendrier il a choisi
ces médias nationaux pour s'exprimer
ben voilà c'est sa liberté moi si vous
connaissez ma position je pense que ou
bien il ya un candidat naturel je pense
que il fait ce pari d'être à plus de 20%
dans les sondages rapidement pour tuer
le match
voilà et à ce moment là il devient notre
candidat naturel messi a pas ce candidat
naturel
il faudra trouver une procédure une
règle commune qui n'est pas seulement un
vote pour départager
mais qu'ils aient la certitude que même
si on a un champion déterminé par un
vote
voilà de départage il faudra ensuite une
équipe de france on aura besoin de tous
les talents
évidemment de celui aussi de 10 à vivre
cette équipe de france elle pourrait
elle pourrait aboutir une alliance entre
xavier bertrand et vous finalement vous
retrouvez le retour de l'autorité de
l'état enfin j'ai repris la restauration
de la valeur travail reprendre le
contrôle sur l'immigration la république
territoire enfin vous ne pouvez être
cardiaque d'accord avec lui en fait
c'est quand même rassurant c'est quand
même rassurant que dans une famille
politique élargi puisque xavier a fait
le choix de quitter l air et j'ai fait
le choix de rester à l air qu on ait des
points communs il ya bien entendu des
différences de tempérament il ya des
différences parfois de lignes qui
peuvent s'exprimer
ce que je veux dire justement c'est que
on aura besoin bien sûr de xavier
bertrand de valérie pécresse de laurent
wauquiez 2 michel barnier et d'autres
pour présenter moi ce que je
souhaiterais voyez c'est pas seulement
qu'on ait un vote de départage mais
c'est qui est une règle commune et que
tout ce petit monde tous ces candidats
là puisse dire écoutez on fera tous
ensemble une équipe parce que la
situation sera dramatique le bilan des
mails macron ne sera pas bon voilà on le
sait déjà et il faudra redresser la
france
on aura besoin de tout le monde bertrand
que julien le rappeler il avait fait
delà des régionales une sorte de
primaire la région pays de la loire elle
est dirigée par une offre très proche
christelle morançais est ce que si cette
région est perdue pour les républicains
ce sera en france pour votre candidature
à la différence de xavier j'ai toujours
indiqué que le départage il ya la
primaire il y allait bien sûr il ya les
régionales il ya les départementales
quand les gens votent pour
comment dirais-je une collectivité ils
votent pour désigner ceux qui vont
diriger la collectivité je veux dire
c'est que les citoyens sont adultes
voilà et ils ne confondent pas les
départementales et régionales et les
présidentielles
les enjeux ne sont pas les mêmes et je
souhaite vraiment que xavier et je le
pense puisse remporter cette élection
régionale j'avais moi même concouru en
2015 c'est des élections qui sont
difficiles et je pense à bien vos
parties
pourrais je l'avais emporté mais
j'espère bien qu'il le qui l'emportera
vous avez cité quelques quelques noms de
personnes qui pourraient être utiles
dans votre camp mais alors il y en a un
que vous n'avez pas cité je sais pas si
c'est à dessein c'est edouard edouard
philippe qui en ce moment le gars
populaire auprès de qui tout le monde
veut se prendre en photo
est-ce que vous pensez que qui pourrait
servir votre camp non mais je pense que
edouard philippe est dans le camp des
mâles macro et il me semble que human
macron sera candidat aux présidentielles
et que par conséquent edouard philippe
ne pourra pas faire acte de candidature
il l'a d'ailleurs plutôt 10 à angers
c'était dans l'ouest le 25 septembre
dernier j'avais retenu cette phrase où
il parlait les aventures individuelles
donc moi j'en prends acte voilà après on
peut avoir c'est à dire que free ne peut
pas être le candidat de la droite où le
candidat soutenu par la droite celle je
pense qu'il sera pas je pense que à
partir du moment
je pense qu'il est il est loyal sa
loyauté va à emmanuel macron qu'il avait
fait premier ministre en 2017 à partir
de là les choses sont dites c'est tout
vous ne croyez pas la piste du recours
le recours si emmanuel macron étaient
empêchés je pense que mails macron ça ne
vous a pas échappé vous qui êtes un fin
observateur n'est pas françois hollande
et je pense que quoi qu'il en coûte
il sera candidat merci beaucoup merci
madame royal était notre invité ce matin
la une de la voix du nord écoles
vacances on change tout évidemment vous
revenez sur les annonces
macron merci beaucoup
[Musique]